On June 12 2016 I woke up like any other
Sunday morning and like any other
millennial instinctively checked my
phone I merely saw two words splashed
across news outlets and social media
Orlando and shooting my first thought
was oh it must be about the shooting
that happened last week so I shrugged
rapped a rainbow handkerchief round my
neck and traversed a few blocks
separated my apartment from the start of
the Los Angeles Pride Parade it was then
in there surrounded by a sea of fellow
LGBT Cuban marchers surrounded by family
that it became common knowledge that a
very similar celebratory crowd of
vibrant young people had just hours
before it been gunned down at pulse
nightclub what would be called the worst
mass shooting in modern US history
I realized throughout the following week
as my friends posted eulogies for
victims who they knew in the massacre
that the degrees of separation between
these events and me don't exist anymore
in fact I wondered if they ever existed
at all and it dawned on me too the
longest most influential relationship I
never knew I had in my life is with mass
shootings these tragedies have been
brutally effective in shaping my
worldview so I I don't want to speak on
this topic as some self purported expert
like you'll see flooding your feets but
for more of a sincere experiential
perspective I can remember exactly where
I was and what I was doing for every
major massacre in my lifetime and more
often than not the victims and the
perpetrators were around my age I'm
stuck in a cyclical pattern of abuse in
this relationship but it wasn't always
like this and it has gotten much much
worse when I was 5 years old a man
crashed his pickup truck into a chain
restaurant called luby's about an hour
and a half from where I lived and shot
and killed over 20 people my father to
calm my fears recounted an infamous
school shooting that had happened in the
1960s as we drove past the clock tower
at the University of Texas he pointed at
it and reassured me that was the last
time something bad like this happened
around here these things don't happen
often so don't be scared
little did he know at the time that he
had only lived through around 20 US mass
shootings before I was born by today
I've lived through over 100 and Counting
and it all began at Columbine I was 13
years old and I can vividly remember
sitting in front of my television set in
my living room watching the news replay
this
of countless students running out of the
school with their hands on their heads
teenagers my age were dangling from
broken windows trying to escape
Columbine changed everything and as the
adults argued politics we kids actually
went through a massive tonal shift when
it came to our perspective on our peers
and our culture and security and that's
when I grew paranoid because our parents
had Wars and we had Columbine I remember
schools installing metal detectors at
their entrances and I remember that it
became a common sick practical joke for
some idiot to call a bomb threat just to
watch everyone get evacuated
I remember rock music and video games
and even the internet being blamed and
if you wore a trenchcoat you were killer
we were very quick and eager to turn on
one another everyone debated about who
or what was at fault and if history has
taught us anything there was no easy
answer kids were dead and nothing was
done and then 9/11 happened and our
generation went from cautiously
skeptical to absolutely terrified
Columbine ignited our fears young
citizens than 911 to find it to be
rampant righteous and unending and why
not we were scared we wanted answers but
instead of reaching for a common goal we
split ourselves in two and every
conversation you have every fight online
you'll see in the comments below and
every election year we witness this
endless back and forth as more people
die and less resolutions are reached
years later while I was attending film
school the University of Southern
California I was two weeks away from
publicly premiering a short film which
had already wrapped when the deadliest
attack at that time happened on the
opposite coast on a campus much like
mine and in some twisted sense of
timeliness my short film was a graphic
critique of school shootings remember
mother of one of my friends walked up to
me and remarked you should watch what
you make since it looks like your kind
or prone to violence Virginia Tech like
any other massacre involving a wide
array of players from different
backgrounds whether it was racial
religious or cultural brought forth an
ugliness that directly affected me for
the first time and as we've mourned the
dead it struck me that every time that
this happens it not only opens up an
opportunity advance personal political
agendas it becomes top priority for most
of us to do so and yet again kids were
dead nothing was done and Omaha
Binghamton Fort Hood twice Fort Hood in
the same town as that loogies cafeteria
that was shot up in my childhood schools
malls churches post office military
bases a grocery store parking lot in
Tucson
and then a movie theater in Aurora
during a midnight screen the Dark Knight
Rises where was I waiting to attend a
midnight screening of the Dark Knight
Rises
we all could have been those victims
excitedly waiting to watch a blockbuster
on opening night no one was safe and
then later that year over 20 people the
majority being children from the first
grade were shot and killed at Sandy Hook
our little brothers and sisters our own
children gunned down my gut reaction was
well now things will definitely have to
change but it did not little kids were
dead and nothing was done Santa Monica
Santa Barbara Marysville Umpqua
Charleston I apologize if I'm forgetting
some but there's just too many to count
so many that I becoming so used to
turning from passionate rage to
desensitize resignation on a dime I only
shrugged I screamed and then I shrugged
and then I forgot our interconnectedness
not only as a nation but also the
international community the internet
social media and bullet holes are like
the connected dots that link our
generation beyond each other's shores
Paris my second home where my mother has
lived for over 17 years was hit by a
series of unfathomable terrorist attacks
and my immediate bleak thought was my
mother is dead thankfully she was
unharmed but we have come to such a low
point as a global society where we
assume the absolute worst because is how
we already view one another's human
beings and then less than a month later
San Bernardino happened and my mother
returned the favor and had to call me to
see if I was okay our entire office on
Sunset Boulevard heard the sirens
driving eastward to San Bernardino less
than an hour away and in the following
week we'd hold a security meeting on
what to do in an active shooter
situation what was once video games and
trench coats has morphed into the red
flag du jour for politicians who have
ensured especially with our upcoming
election that we are a country solely
operating on our fear we have let the
politicians and Talking Heads and online
forums dictate a conversation that our
generation needs to have about our role
in the fight against violence we grew up
on these mass shootings the victims and
unfortunately the shooters are people we
all personally know Orlando provided a
spy light on a real issue this
disconnect between those who write the
narrative and those who are actually
living it most our leaders are not what
the victims were primarily LGBTQ Latin
ex black and young
in fact many many a politician aim to
marginalize those groups today we are
passionate and over educated but
desensitized and underrepresented and
thus we have become divided just like
the generations before us but instead we
need to consider shutting the [ __ ] up
for a second and actually doing
something about it the patrons of pulse
were targeted because who they were they
were queer people of color and you as
Millennials out there all no one loves
someone from those backgrounds and not
all politicians do it's fine to share
their speeches in your opinions even
about this very video but posting in the
infinite soap box that is the Internet
is like prayer without action contact
your elected officials because
eventually we're going to become those
elect officials so merely shrugging at
politics instead of actively
participating it will not change the
game let's get up all in their business
because if Orlando has taught us
anything it's that they need to know
that we cannot watch any more of our
friends and loved ones die and I'll be
damned if kids who are watching this
right now will grow up to become another
statistic because we blindly join a
system that loves to argue about
problems we refuses to produce actual
results mass shootings they have been my
longest most influential relationship
yes but from this moment on it will be I
who defines it when I look back on June
12 2016 I will not only remember the
deaths of the innocent but what we did
to finally make a change and finally to
the LGBT community know that you are
brave and that you were strong and loved
and how we are with you
you
you